hi guys sci-fi recapped here welcome
back to the black mirror series recap
before we start morning
spoilers ahead
today i'm going to explain a drama
science fiction series from black mirror
seasons 2 called be right back
in this episode it will tell a story
about loss and the way we cope with it
when lives are immortalized through the
use of the internet and social media
this episode is not just a reflection on
grief in the digital age but also on the
intangible side of humans that make up
the people we love
the movie begins with martha and ash a
young and romantic couple who just moved
to a remote house in the countryside ash
is a social media addict and
compulsively checks his phone for
updates on his social network pages
while martha is currently working as an
illustrator
there ash tells martha that his mom
always kept all the photos and memories
of the deceased ones in the attic
especially when his brother and his dad
died after dinner the couple have
intercourse not knowing that it will be
the last time they do it together the
next day ash goes out alone to return
the rendered van to the owner
martha refuses to join because she has a
deadline that needs to be finished by
the end of the day
it's already night but ash still has not
come back
when martha calls the van's owner she
says that the van has not been returned
and this makes her very worried
a few moments later a police car comes
across to their house claiming that ash
has been killed in a car accident this
accident leaves martha alone and grief
stricken in an unfamiliar house of his
deceased boyfriend
at the funeral one of martha's friends
sarah tells her about a new online
service which allows people to talk and
interact with the deceased one
with good intention she also signs
martha up to the platform without
telling her hoping that she will get
better
at first martha rejects the offer and
walks away from sarah
days goes by martha tries to move on
from ash and starts redecorating the
house
while checking her email she discovers
that sarah had signed her up to the new
online service and she also spots an
email from the death ash
she manages to ignore that email at the
beginning but sarah explains that the
system works by collecting and using all
ash's past online communication and
social media profiles creating a new
virtual profile of ash
she then is overwhelmed by grief and
soon discovers that she is pregnant
becoming emotionally unstable she
finally decides to respond to the
artificial ash's email she starts to
communicate with him through instant
messaging she also informs her pregnancy
to the android ash demand for more
martha starts uploading videos and
photos of ash to the platform's database
allowing it to duplicate ash's voice to
talk with martha over the phone
the android's voice surprises martha
because it talks in the same way as ash
martha begins to believe that she is
really talking to her dead boyfriend
she becomes addicted to it as she keeps
talking to the android ash almost
non-stop ignoring the calls from her
sister
it turns out that the android ash is
also able to process visual information
by using the camera on martha's phone
martha also keeps the android ash
updated about her pregnancy condition
while walking out from the hospital
martha accidentally drops her phone and
suddenly has a panic attack when she
temporarily disconnects from the android
ash inevitably martha craves more as
it's not enough to just talk on the
phone
thus the android ash tells her about the
advanced technology from the online
service provider that is still in its
experimental phase even though it is not
cheap martha decides to buy it
the product turns out to be a body made
of synthetic flesh that android ash can
be uploaded into
magic happens after martha finishes
activating the body the end result is an
android that looks almost exactly like
ash only missing minor details such as a
mole on his neck which appears as soon
as martha talks about it despite the
android manages to satisfy her sexually
she quickly becomes frustrated by it
constantly doing what she says without
question
the differences between the real ash and
android ash becomes obvious
though it can duplicate ash's skin
pattern almost exactly the same it just
can't perform human emotions
it can laugh but it can't feel joy
even when it is in the same room it
leaves martha on her own now with the
added burden of trying to convince
herself to love an android version of
ash
one night martha realizes that she can't
sleep next to him knowing it is not real
and forces him to leave which he
immediately does causing her to snap at
him and tell him the real ash wouldn't
just leave and would argue about it but
android ash is incapable of that
martha finally demands it to leave the
house and he does
the next morning she finds it standing
near the fence of the house
android ash explains that it can't go
further than a certain distance from the
activation point which is the house
unless martha is with him
martha then desperately brings the
android to the edge of a tall cliff and
orders it to jump off it agrees to do so
but that only makes martha even angrier
saying that the real ash would not have
willingly jumped instead would be afraid
and cry for his life
the android ash responds by begging for
its own life causing martha to realize
that she can't bring herself to get rid
of it
the scene jumps to several years later
martha is shown to have raised her
daughter and still lives in the
countryside house keeping the android
ash in the attic as they cut the cake
her daughter asks from another piece
claiming it will be for android ash in
the attic she only allows her daughter
to see it on weekends but it's her
daughter's birthday so she's allowed to
go into the attic to give the android a
piece of birthday cake
her daughter reveals in the conversation
with the android that she knows it does
not eat so she just uses him to get an
extra slice of the cake the girl then
asks her mom to come up and join them
and after some hesitation she does
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching